[Musique]
c'est une langue qui est importante dans
notre société car tous les Maliens toute
la population malienne parle presque
dans ce langues quoi donc c'est très
important
d'apprendre le bamakan
[Musique]
les tendances ont montrées depuis la
mise en circulation du draft de
constitutions que les Maliens pour une
grande majorité sont pour que les
langues nationales occupent une plus
grande place dans la sphère publique
cela ne veut pas forcément dire que les
français langue d'expulsion officielle
depuis
1960 soit défini
[Musique]
on va commencer un processus en parlant
de généralisation de l'enseignement de
langue nationale de l'utilisation des
langues nationales de l'école mais ça a
été de mon point de vue un coup de pied
dans l'eau parce que en dépit d'un grand
moyen éjecté de la de la de l'engagement
des écrivains ou des éditeurs
certains pensent que on va imposer on va
leur imposer les bamakas et mais il n'y
aura pas d'imposition tout ça sera
discuté
[Musique]